nous accueillons ce soir monsieur
bernard rougier dr en sciences
politiques diplômé de l'iep et de paris
qui a enseigné à l'université saint
joseph de beyrouth au liban entre 96 et
2002 puis devenu chercheur à l'institut
français du proche-orient en jordanie
de 2011 à 2015 avait dirigé le centre
d'études et de documentation économiques
juridiques et sociales du caire puis à
partir de 2015
vous avez conseillé par don à
l'université sorbonne nouvelle en
sociologie et politologie du monde arabe
naturellement il ya beaucoup de
publications de votre part ils sont
heureux de vous recevoir ce soir puisque
la commission des lois naturellement est
saisie du texte sur le confortement des
valeurs de la république
ce texte viendra très proches au mois de
mars en commission des lois le 17 il en
séance publique le 30 mars
les deux rapporteurs de la commission
des lois sont présentes
madame eustache brinio et madame v rien
et les autres collègues ici je note
d'ailleurs une présence est
exclusivement féminine des commissaires
aux lois il va rallier peut-être un
rappel au règlement
et donc on posera une série de questions
voilà de ses plaisanteries de fin
d'après midi
on vit vous avez la parole monsieur le
président vous voulez que je fasse une
un exposé coin de 10 15 minutes et et
après on fait un échange et je suis tenu
de parler avec avec le masque
malheureusement honnêtement oui vous
êtes à distance largement respect qu'il
doit y avoir une tolérance ainsi vous
pouvez l'enlever si vous souhaitez il ya
c'est très gentil naissance il ya pas
difficultés déjà dit que nous avons des
collègues qui sont en visioconférence
j'aperçois monsieur jean yves lecompte
qui est un sénateur des français de
l'étranger manque de la correctionnelle
madame à un français que c'est mieux
d'avoir le mas si vous voulez je le mets
ici aussi foz puis je me plie à la loi
l'administration a fait alors absolument
donc monsieur le président j'ai si vous
voulez vous avez eu la gentillesse de
rappeler très brièvement mon parcours
universitaire et il est vrai que j'ai
passé sur les vingt dernières années de
ma vie où les 25 dernières années de ma
vie
davantage de temps au moyen-orient que
qu'en france et lorsque je suis revenu
j'allais dire définitivement à paris et
que j'ai pris mes fonctions de
professeur des universités à la sorbonne
nouvelle
je me suis intéressé évidemment aux
manifestations de rupture au discours de
rupture qui pouvait avoir lieu dans la
société française avec la connaissance
évidemment des processus étudié au liban
en jordanie en egypte en syrie aussi
pendant pendant les 20 25 années
écoulées et l'idée était de
de commencer un travail sur sur les
discours et les pratiques de rupture et
d'y aller de manière très naïf si vous
voulez presque phénoménologique en
rappelant le l'enseignement du serl
essayer d'oublier un peu tout ce qui
s'était dit constitué comme savoir et
naïvement demandé à des étudiants ou à
des membres de mon équipe plus largement
d'aller dans des mosquées de prier
l'équipe était composée de d'étudiants
et de volontaires musulmans
je leur ai demandé si ça posait un
problème pas du tout mon style répondu
parce que il ne se sentait pas du tout
représentée par un discours islamiste
qu'ils avaient identifié comme tel et
donc l'idée était de savoir ce qui se
disait ce qui se faisait à la fois lors
de la prédication du vendredi dans des
cours qui étaient donnés éventuellement
dans des cours d'arabe dans des la
manière dont la route balle au prêche
était été reçus la manière dont les gens
décrivent est en quelque sorte leur
rapport à la société française et la
manière dont si vous voulez s'opérait ce
que j'ai appelé le décodage religieux de
la société française c'est à dire de
quelle manière ces sociétés on est venu
à être traduites par des termes de
l'arabe du coran parfois le plus souvent
dus à 10 donc dudit prophétique de la
parole attribuée au prophète de l'islam
dans telle ou telle situation
et si vous voulez il ya eu à la fois
dans les prêches les conversations dans
les librairies islamiques qui était
également utilisée on a vu tout un
travail de 2 g les dires de huy de
décodage de traduction de la société
française de décodage alors ça donnera
par exemple la survalorisation d'un à
dix d'indy prophétique
selon lequel
magne aux biches à ben arab farouq aminu
ce qui signifie celui qui ressemble à un
autre peuple en devient membre devient
membre de ce peuple
vous voyez donc c'est l'idée ne vous
n'allez pas vous fondre dans la société
française refusé l'intégration
l'assimilation quel que soit le nom
qu'on lui donne et entre guillemets
restez vous même enfermé dans une
identité qui n'est pas et ça c'est
important qui n'est pas d'identité
prescrite si vous voulez l'identité de
naissance ethnoculturelles mais qui est
une identité idéologique et très
rapidement ce qui nous a intéressés
c'est de voir comment les héritages
ethnoculturelles nationaux et est
retravaillée par des des individus alors
dans notre jargon on peut les appeler
des entrepreneurs idéologique des
entrepreneurs de cause voir des
entrepreneurs de colère et la manière
dont ils essaient de redessiner en
quelques sortes
l'identité collective d'une partie d'une
partie des fidèles je dis bien une
partie parce que je ne doute pas que
pour la majorité des croyants qui vont à
la mosquée le vendredi
ces enjeux sont très éloignés mais ce
qui nous a frappés c'est de voir que
l'offre présenter l'offre d' islam était
souvent pas toujours pas
systématiquement mais souvent dans les
différentes mosquées étudié était
teintée d'idéologie avec une j'allais
dire une orientation salafistes y
compris par des groupes qui ne se
réclame mais pas du salafisme et on
s'est aperçu que un certain nombre de
deux mots code issu du salafisme et est
également employé encore une fois par
des des associations que ce soit le
tablir que ce soit les frères musulmans
qui ne se réclament pas exclusivement du
salafisme
donc il faut bien voir le salafisme non
pas comme une comme un secteur identifié
un certain nombre de mosquées mais bien
comme une sensibilité qui imprègne un
milieu qui va bien au delà des cercles
qui s'en réclament exclusivement et une
autre étude extérieure celle ci d'adler
ce wheeling nous montrer de manière
quantitative cette fois
le nombre de livres issus de cette
littérature salafistes saoudienne pour
la plupart dans les librairies
islamiques de manière très
impressionnante à la fois les livres
pour enfants les jouets tout la
socialisation s'opère sur sur des
critères salafistes sur vraiment mais de
manière presque caricatural il ya une
c'est ce que j'ai appelé la redéfinition
de l'islam sachant que avoir passé vingt
années au moyen-orient pour revenir
juste un instant sur l'équation
personnelle me décomplexer d'une
certaine manière puisque mes amis y
compris des réfugiés palestiniens dans
les camps souffrait de cette
islamisation de la prédication
ils m'ont aidé et eau et des
intellectuels que j'ai rencontrés au
caire et à beyrouth me disais que
c'était une trahison du sens à leurs
yeux un os qui était pratiquement du
sens de l'islam et de la même façon dont
ils interprétaient donc tout ça m'a mis
évidemment tout à fait à l'aise et on a
travaillé donc à la fois sur la
prédication sur les expressions diverses
sur les liens éventuels dans certains
cas avec les municipalités en place sur
des mécanismes de clientèle souvent très
subtiles qui se disaient pas comme tel
mais qui était une fois qu'on
travaillait un terrain c'est à dire ces
terrains ont été travaillés pendant
plusieurs années n'ont pas été et ils ne
se sont pas ceux sont pas des terrains
qu'ils ont été j'allais dire bâclé mais
au contraire qui ont été travaillés avec
patience parce que ces processus on ne
peut les comprendre que qu'avec le temps
si vous voulez avec le temps et avec la
pratique
et puis on pouvait aussi s'apercevoir de
avant la crise du coc vide de la
circulation permanente survalorisé dans
la tradition ou dans l'expression
salafistes du du voyage à la mecque et à
médine du petit pèlerinage de la omra
qui permet à chaque fois de se
ressourcer de trouver des livres des
contacts des réseaux d des prédicateurs
qui vont alimenter cette retranscription
de la société française dans des termes
islam aux salafistes si vous voulez les
on a assisté à des leçons sur les femmes
qui étaient en fait là la transposition
de leçons qui était donné dans tel ou
tel institut ollier mène en arabie
saoudite pour décrire la manière dont
les femmes devaient se conduire en
occident avec des a-10 aussi incroyable
que les femmes sont le combustible de
l'enfer et c'est tout ça et dit tout ça
est connu on en a pas on n'a pas inventé
si vous voulez et et de la manière dont
ce qui nous a frappés aussi c'est la
manière dont les acteurs religieux
mettait en avant une prétendue identité
religieuse alors qu'il y avait au delà
de cette identité religieuse un projet
idéologique
alors quand on vous prend un peu de
recul je vais vraiment pas être très
long pour essayer de comprendre comment
cette métamorphose est opérée sur les 20
25 dernières années
bien sûr nous avions déjà des
organisations il y avait lui aussi à
fond dont on pense connaître le rôle au
moins dans la crise du du voile à creil
en 89
il ya l'organisation du tablir donc vous
savez des méthodes prédication de rue
qui sont qui sont évidemment utiliser
comme prédication itinérante extrêmement
efficace sur trois jours quarante jours
ou trois mois où il faut essayer de
convertir ou au moins de ramener à leur
conception de la foi mais ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que ces deux
matrices celle du tablir d'une part et
celle des frères musulmans d'autre part
ont été travaillés en amont par cette
sensibilité salafistes et qu'on voit une
salle à feeding crise à l'intérieur du
tablier entre les les anciens de cette
organisation qui sont dans le marquage
le siège central à saint-denis et
d'autres courants plus jeunes
extrêmement exposées aux critiques
salafiste et qui vont modifier également
leurs discours pour être compétitif en
quelque sorte en quelque sorte dans la
rue ce qui nous avait évidemment
donc il ya ce travail alors la nouveauté
ce sont à partir des années 90
probablement la crise du golfe
l'invasion du koweït par saddam hussein
et la mise en place d'une politique très
agressive sur le plan religieux par
l'arabie saoudite
après cette période parce que l'opinion
arabe pour le dire très vite et y
compris
les jeunes d'origine arabe en france ont
pris fait et cause pour saddam hussein
et donc il fallait d'une certaine
manière travailler cette société ensuite
il ya eu le 11 septembre
l'explication que évidemment ben laden
et autres n'avaient rien compris à
l'islam qu'il fallait propager le vrai
islam dont il ya eu ces événements
internationaux qui ont suscité une
diplomatie plus active financièrement
évidemment mais surtout aussi par
l'invitation de professeur de chaire de
représentants institutionnels qui ont
alimenté des conférences en région
parisienne sur le salafisme ça
correspondait à ce que j'ai appelé la
révolution salafiste c'est à dire la
redécouverte de la foi à travers le à 10
justement pas le corps en réalité au pas
seulement le coran qui est un texte
évidemment polysémique difficile à
utiliser comme tout texte sacré avec des
contradictions des expressions poétiques
des expressions juridique d expression
et scatologiques mais en revanche les
milliers de à 10 pouvait en quelque
sorte être en équivalence avec des
situations de la vie quotidienne plus
l'apprentissage de l'arabe qui a
commencé aussi à cette partie à cette
partie à cette trêve
pardon à cette période on est dans une
dans un énorme de travail de
redéfinition de soi ça passe par des
créations de revue par l'invitation de
cheikh salafiste part évidemment la
révolution des réseaux sociaux
les consultations qu on peut faire
directement donc tous ces événements là
prennent sens après la chute du mur dans
des dans des logiques de réseaux des
logiques de capillarité des logiques
générationnel puisque les jeunes
évidemment considère que les parents ne
sont pas des vrais musulmans que eux
seuls ont l'application du véritable
islam et qu'il ya des conflits
intrafamiliaux assez violent et il faut
pas prendre au pied de la lettre
évidemment ceux qui disent notamment
dans des rapports judiciaire mes parents
ne sont pas musulmans si bien sûr ils
sont musulmans mais pas de la même
manière
et enfin pour terminer avec les
événements dramatiques de l'année 2015
et ceux qui ont suivi la grande question
qui se pose est dans le milieu de la
recherche c'est de dire est ce que le
djihadisme est un champ apparaît d'un
champ isolé avec des individus qui
rentreraient directement dans dans ce
champ de la lune
violente au fond de l'attentât du
terrorisme ou est ce qu'il ya des
passerelles une porosité entre d'autres
cercles de socialisation si vous voulez
ou les individus ont pu recouvrer un
argumentaire puiserait des
représentations des conceptions
justifiant le passage à l'acte et on a
pu grâce à des travaux et des entretiens
qui ont été faits avec des acteurs jia
distant prison voir que pas tout ça mais
pour une majorité très large d'entre eux
au moins les trois quarts
il y avait eu des passages soit dans des
expériences dites salafistes soit dans
des expériences jihadistes il ya le cas
d'un d'un jeu jihadistes dont le
parcours était évidemment idéal typique
pour ma démonstration
il m'a dit qu'il a été convertie grâce
aux tab lire mais que ce n'était pas
assez solide sur le plan religieux
il va trouver chez les frères musulmans
des éléments intellectuelle beaucoup
plus roboratif
mais il ya une mixité qui lui déplaît il
va aller chez chez les salafistes ou là
il ya plus de mixité on attaque les
textes on les traduit on travaille
l'arabe mais il ya l'allégeance entre
les états unis la relation privilégiée
entre les états unis l'arabie saoudite
qui déplaît donc la solution de synthèse
ou foncée logis à 10 mhz qui n'est pas
mixte qui est sérieux ou ont travaillé
les textes et on est anti américain il y
avait là bon ce type de lui c'était
vraiment un exemple idéal typique en
quelque sorte mais de montrer au fond
les les mécanismes de rupture les
mécanismes dans le rapport à la société
française et la manière dont cette
petite musique circulez y compris dans
des institutions comme l'université
comme les syndicats étudiants et est
donc d'essayer de comprendre quelque
sorte les logiques intellectuelle
sociale géopolitique qui pouvaient dans
l'univers des prisons dans l'univers des
quartiers dans l'est dans les mosquées
transformer en quelque sorte
l'expression de l'islam de france et
avoir un lien entre l'action violente et
la radicalisation dit non violente non
violente au sens physique mais qui selon
nous produisent et une violence
symbolique c'est à travers la
description de l'état de la laïcité
comme une machine machine à détruire
l'islam etc etc
donc voila un petit peu le travail que
nous avons fait et qui a suscité
polémiques controverse mais on avait
souhaité moi et ceux qui ont participé à
ce livre que cette polémique fut
davantage scientifique avec des contres
terrain et pas et pas sur le mode
l'insultent voire de la menace toi merci
non jeu
j'avais une question qui était posée par
un col avec une garde pour tout à
l'heure je vous réponds cela poserait
peut-être des questions de madame
monsieur bruno il n'avait rien alors des
questions oui puis êtes en relation
parents protestent parce que bon c'est
vrai que le fait partie de ces
chercheurs qui ont ouvert en tout cas
des pistes de réflexion et surtout
qu'ils ont posé les choses telles
qu'elles existent aujourd'hui vos livres
et vous revoilà on les femmes on mange
les élus on retrouve ce que vous avez
exposé sur ses discours et ses pratiques
de rupture qui sont une réalité
vous avez vous l'avez aussi positionné
dans le temps et d'ailleurs la dame qui
était h 15 ans avant vous ou sur
lesquels on a parlé de laïcité a
pratiquement donné la même temporalité
aux événements sarko alors en gros les
atteindre les insectes forte contre la
laïcité remonte à 20 ans et vous vous
remontez aussi certains événements
m'attends donc ça fait 20 ans que notre
société française est entre guillemets
infiltrés par ces phénomènes des frères
musulmans des salafistes d'établir on le
voit on le voit c'est une réalité
ce texte de loi n'arrive pas par hasard
voilà vous avez souvent parlé dans vos
propos dans vos livres dans vos
descriptions d'écosystèmes qui se
construisait je pense que ça serait
peut-être bien vous puissiez revenir sur
ces écosystèmes parce que c'est l'un des
sujets majeurs sur lequel ça va être
difficile de travailler
en tout cas c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut composent ces écosystèmes c'est à
dire ces quartiers entiers qui sortent
de la république vous les avez souvent
bien décrit donc ça serait peut-être
bien que vous puissiez nous dire
quelques mots là-dessus et moi j'aurais
envie de vous dire ce texte je sais pas
si vous l'avez regardé
bon voilà donc si vous l'avez regardé
est ce qu'il est ce que voilà c'est
facile c'est pas des textes toujours
très bas mais m
si vous avez regardé ce texte est ce qui
vous parce que vous pensez qu'ils
répondent à certaines interrogations et
en quoi ils y répondent est ce qu'il
donne des clés simplement de quelque
chose qu'il faudra continuer à écrire
c'est aussi une question est alors de
manière brutale pensez vous que parfois
dans certains quartiers certains lieux
c'est déjà trop tard
posons nous la question merci merci je
suis président merci monsieur rouzier
d'être là donc j'ai également lu votre
livre et du coup j'ai un certain nombre
d'interrogations alors qu'on
probablement plus par rapport à vos
travaux que par pro texte de loi mais ma
collègue nous a déjà posé des questions
essentiels par rapport à ce texte dans
ce que je lis et que les extrémismes
sont de plusieurs sortes et notamment
donc les salafistes sont relativement
peu politique
finalement ils sont séparatiste mais pas
forcément politique est-ce qu'on doit
encore parler d'islam politique ou pas
puisque pour le coup là on est plus sûr
du séparatisme
ça fait un peu peur parce que quand on
le lit on a l'impression que où qu'on
soit c'est comme ça que ça se passe
et peut-être que où qu'on soit pourvu
que il y ait des musulmans dans un
quartier c'est comme ça que ça se passe
est ce le cas où est ce que vraiment
c'est encore assez circonscrit peut-être
dans des endroits où pour le coup c'est
un peu perdu mais est-ce que c'est quand
même assez circonscrit ou vraiment
est-ce que ça a fait tâche d'huile à peu
près sûr toute la communauté
y at il du coup une force musulmane
modérée qui viendraient contact
contrecarrer ces mouvements extrémistes
est elle suffisamment puissante en
interne pour pouvoir lutter contre ces
mouvements extrémistes et enfin
le statut de l'homme et de la femme
clairement différenciés et qui semble
être un des points majeurs d'ailleurs
quand on lit et là qui est partagé par
tous les différents courants extrémistes
donc c'est clair que c'est une
composante importante de l'islamisme
n'est t'elle pas une composante de
l'islam et des modérés dont je parlais
s'il existait s'ils sont forts sur ce
sujet ont-ils aussi avancé où malgré
tout il ya encore y at il encore un gros
travail à faire si vous n'avez rien nous
avons deux collègues qui sont en en
visioconférence le ministre monsieur
alain richard et monsieur jean yves
lecompte qui a demandé la parole je lui
donnais tout de suite s'il nous entend
oui oui tout à fait vous m'entendez vous
pouvez très bien voulu être président et
merci pour cet exposé exposé qui
finalement montre que la lutte contre
l'islamisme radical et le développement
de l'islamisme radical n'est pas une
situation française mais une situation
mondiale
finalement qui est constatée du sel
jusqu'à la tchétchénie au moins et qu'on
peut aussi effectivement il ya des dates
peut-être l'affaiblissement du
nassérisme 79 à tout ça qu'est ce que
est ce que vous pensez qu'on aborde les
choses correctement aujourd'hui en
france en présente à ça comme un combat
franco-français comme une situation
franco française il faudrait s'intégrer
ou participer ou est-ce que ce que nous
faisons actuellement nous donne une
position pour pouvoir finalement
participer à quelque chose qui est plus
large et aussi qui tient compte de
l'expérience qu'on peut constater dans
un certain nombre de pays où ça a été
vite sensible je pense à l'algérie je
pensais l'egypte mais aussi à
l'évolution de l'iran ou du liban est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire si ce que vous
sentez comme réaction aujourd'hui en
france a plutôt tendance à nous exclure
ou nous permettre de tirer correctement
les expériences d
une expérience qui se sont passées
ailleurs en matière de lutte contre
l'islamisme radical
merci monsieur le comte la dernière
question en tous les cas une première
série peut-être à mais la parole est un
monsieur richard et a su président j'ai
eu aussi deux questions qui sont plus
dans la ligne de la réflexion de madame
derrien toute la leur c'est au fond
mieux comprendre l'étendue et les
limites du phénomène dans la société
française je devrais m'en souvenir parce
que je pense que vous l'avez mentionné
dans le début de votre livre mais
comment avez vous choisi les sites où
vous avez envoyé vos observateurs est ce
que c'est à partir d'informations vous
aviez déjà identifié enfin qui laissait
supposer que ces sites étaient des sites
de pénétration salafistes ou est-ce que
c'est randomisés c'est à dire est-ce que
c'est au fond un échantillon
représentatif et donc à travers ça est
ce qu'on peut dire que vous avez une
mesure de l'étendue du phénomène
la deuxième question qui m'est aussi
inspiré par ce que disait madame p rien
c'est au fond nous avons le sujet
mosquée et nous avons le sujet quartier
situation de quartiers dans lesquels les
personnes de culture musulmane
représente une majorité prononcer et où
s'exerce une pression et une
communication interne de quartier qui se
ferme de l'extérieur et où les messages
l'intégriste circulent est ce que dans
le cas des décisions culte que vous avez
observé sur longue période
vous pouvez dire que ces lieux de culte
était enracinée dans une zone de vie
spécifique ou est-ce qu'on contre ahmed
et arrosait si j'ose dire des lieux
résidentiels très différents et est ce
que vous pensez qu'il y à une logique
spécifique à la prédication et à la
travail d' influence idéologique dans
les quartiers à très forte majorité
si monsieur achats mais monsieur roger
vous avez la parole vous et merci
beaucoup
j'ai de quoi faire alors vous permettez
que je réponde je vais essayer donc je
fais si garder un ordre dans lorsque je
souhaite alors est ce que c'est une
situation franco françaises n'ont à
l'évidence c'est un débat mondial toutes
les sociétés musulmanes sont concernés
et nous sommes concernés presque par
effet de ce débat de ces expressions de
cette mainmise par des courants de
l'islamisme sur l'expression de l'islam
dont le monde musulman cette révolution
a travaillé le monde musulman et nous en
avons évidemment les effets ce qui est
désolant c'est que ça soit transformée
en débat franco français mais quand
j'avais travaillé et publier ma thèse
sur le court en gie à dist dans les
camps palestiniens du liban je me suis
heurtée exactement mot pour mot aux
mêmes aux même reproches
j'ai pas vu le groupe de rap oui le
groupe de rap existe dans certains coins
du camp si vous voulez mais la
centralité du camp les frontières
invisibles entre tel ou tel quartier
s'étaient déjà présents alors là ça
prenait une dimension encore plus
visible si vous voulez parce que les
courants salafistes avaient décidé de
déchirer les cartes de la palestine et
de déchiré les portraits de yasser
arafat
donc c'était pour qu'il n'y ait rien de
nationalistes parce que le nationalisme
c'est une invention de l'occident
et donc c'est de ces de l'idolâtrie vous
voyez donc je le voyais et donc moi
j'avais choisi de ne pas m'intéresser au
rappeur de tel ou tel camp qui existait
un mais qui n'avait pas l'expression
majoritaire en tous les cas ni là ni la
capacité de contrôler des quartiers et
d'imposer des sanctions et est donc
cette si vous voulez c'étaient les
éléments du débat j'avais été critiqué
par des par des universitaires
américains à l'époque qui estimait que
j'avais être simplifiées
j'avais pas rendu la complexité mais moi
j'avais choisi de travailler sur cet
élément là et cet élément là me
paraissait avoir des conséquences macro
social macropolitique sur les équilibres
internes et donc je reprendrai presque
la même la même logique argumentative
comment choisir les sites
le hasard sauf un c'était le hasard le
complet c'est à dire que mes étudiants
habitat et dans telle ou telle commune
eh ben je leur disais vous aller prier
oui oui on va plier dans la commune et
donc je leur dis nous voilà ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de voir la manière dont
l'école est décrite la manière dont la
laïcité décrite la manière dont les
petites filles sont encouragés ou pas se
comporter de telle ou telle manière et
que les les questions qui étaient posées
dans les dents les leçons dans les
conférences
voyez la manière en quelque sorte on des
lieux institutionnels comme une mosquée
pouvait influencer le comportement d'une
population est ce qu'il ya une
rationalité derrière c'est au moins
c'est logique de lieux oui je crois
qu'il y en a une c'est d'être aussi
proche que possible quand on dirige une
association islamique mais qui peut
présenter nos rien une orientation ou
une expression islamistes
ce sont les lycées les collèges les
écoles
ces deux-là contre socialisation quasi
systématique et quand vous avez si vous
voulez comme on dit des éléments de
langage qui sont dans l'intérêt d'un
d'un cheikh qui vient faire une
conférence d'une personnalité
charismatique qui a des centaines de
milliers de vues sur internet qu'on
retrouve la même chose dans des jouets
ou dans des ou dans des livres dans les
librairies qui sont aussi des lieux de
vente d'artefacts divers et bien quand
on a c'est une vieille leçon de la
sociologie ça remonte à gabriel tarde
même quand vous avez une croyance qui
est confirmé par le cheikh de mosquées
par la librairie par le cheikh dans le
bled par par google et bien vous allez
considérer que c'est l'islam
et vous n'allez même pas comprendre la
tentative pour différencier distinguer
l'islam comme l'idéologie et les l'islam
comme religion
vous n'y arrivais plus donc il ya eu
quand même une j'allais dire une
politique du cygne qui fait que tout
ramène à son identité religieuse et à
l'intérieur de ces identités religieuses
tout ramène à des définitions islamistes
de cette de cette identité et bien sûr
qu'il y à l'écosystème c'est à dire que
bon il y avait le cas célèbre des
recrutements dans le chicken planète
d'autres
je veux pas parler de trappes mais bien
entendu il ya des lieux de sociabilité
que des jeunes se retrouvent à
l'extérieur de la mosquée alors il ya
quelque chose sur les pour répondre à
votre question sur les sites qui me
paraît très important c'est que autant
il ya aussi il ya de la lâcheté des
accommodements chez les élus mais il ya
aussi la lâcheté des accords de branche
et les présidents d'associations
beaucoup sont tout à fait sincère sont
absolument pas islamistes ni même tenté
par le salafisme mais ils ont des
groupes salafistes dans le quartier qui
vont prier dans la mosquée et ils ont
peur ils ont peur qui est des agressions
ils ont père queuille et du sabotage de
la de la prédication le vendredi ils
veulent que ça se passe bien bon ils
vont les laisser faire des lots sont
durant des semaines et après ils
s'étonnent quand ils sont pris entre
guillemets les dans les mains dans le
pot de confiture parce que ils ont
laissé faire ils ont laissé faire par
une petite transaction
puis qui pour eux ne voient là est
nécessaire pour maintenir l'harmonie de
la communauté mais dont il expose un
lieu de culte à une prédication qui ne
contrôle pas et ça c'est un c'est un
problème qu'on a vu plusieurs fois je
vous signale enfin le canton continue
son travail
ils compris dans des mosquées à toulouse
où mohamed merah écouter des prêches
alors il n'a pas il lui a fréquenté
largement les mosquées de bellefontaine
on le sait maintenant quand vous écoutez
dans une de ces mosquées
le discours n'a quasiment pas changé on
va vous expliquer que si vous si vous
êtes une femme et si vous ne portez pas
le jilbab vous n'êtes plus musulmane
donc alors encore une fois il faut que
tous ceux qui me critiquent à écouter et
ou alors se débrouille pour qu'ils aient
aussi des étudiants et qu'il m'explique
pourquoi moi c'est encore une fois c'est
cette offre idéologique elle n'est pas
je ne pense pas qu'elles représentent la
majorité je pense que c'est un courant
significatif mais si l'offre d'islam et
contrôlées par ce type d'acteur il y
aura il y aura inévitablement
inévitablement un problème sur est ce
qu'il est et ce qu'il est trop tard et
sur le banc d'abord sur la différence
islamisme et islam
je pense qu'elle est tellement
nécessaire elle est très nécessaire
parce que ce qui est aussi donne une
certaine liberté c'est de pouvoir lire
ce qui s'écrit en arabe par les
intellectuels musulmans arabes qui sont
moins complexé qui sont plus courageux
et donc quand on lit leurs livres il ya
des tailles critiques de l'islamisme
écrites en arabe où on voit à chaque
fois les des interprétations abusives la
manière dont on explique que le port du
voile serait obligatoire leur s'inscrit
dans une tradition interprétative et
qu'on n'a pas le droit juridiquement de
dire que cette tradition interprétative
et la tradition qui doit s'imposer de
manière autoritaire que c'est un abus
sur le sens c'est un abus sur sur
l'expression de l'islam et donc on a ici
des acteurs qui souvent pas très bien a
raconté comment ce qu'on a pu dire
evs ont intimidé d'une certaine manière
intellectuellement leur leur auditoire
en considérant que leur explication est
la bonne et la seule et la vraie alors
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres discours mais
évidemment il y en a est-ce que
mes amis entre guillemets musulmans
pratiquants qui font beaucoup de qui
écrivent des livres sur ces questions
depuis on a depuis mohamed arkoun cette
tradition en france doivent
impérativement parler non pas seulement
à la télévision c'est déjà bien mais
mais surtout dans les quartiers parce
qu'il faut qu'il y ait une autre parole
si on se situe sur le terrain religieux
des associations qui donnent une autre
définition une autre vision de l'islam
qu'il ya au moins qu'il y ait du
pluralisme dans les quartiers dans
l'expression associative il ya un
phénomène logique très simple si vous
avez un seul critère d'excellence qui
est la pureté religieuse
vous allez avoir une surenchère à
l'intérieur d'un quartier à la pureté
religieuse et la pureté religieuse elle
va se mesurer par le comportement de
rupture vis-à-vis des institutions
françaises c'est celui ou celle qui ira
le plus loin dans la rupture qui pourra
prétendre être le meilleur ou musulmans
voyons on est là la france devient la
variable d'ajustement du de
l'appartenance plus ou moins pures ou de
la sincérité plus ou moins grande du
croyant
si il y à une pluralité de valeur des
critères d'excellence différents comme
ça doit être le cas dans n'importe
quelle société civile il n'y aura plus
ce phénomène de de surenchère l'hymne
éthique où chacun prétend aller plus
loin dans l'application de la loi
religieuse et donc condamnés ou
s'éloigner encore plus de la société
française une question avait été avait
été posée sur sur l'islam donc l'islam
l'islamisme
oui l'islamisme djihadiste le caractère
politique c'était votre question bien
sûr le salafisme ne prétend pas
contrôler les institutions puisque pour
lui les institutions sont diaboliques
puisqu'elle ne s'inspire pas de la
souveraineté divine en quelque sorte
mais ils font là de la politique au sens
symbolique
ils définissent l'appartenance ils
définissent la société ils les
catégorise ils diffusent des
représentations et donc ça un effet
politique
c'est à ce travail symbolique de
de nommer les choses de nommer les
institutions par transposition de
concepts coranique pour dire ta route
pour désigner un pouvoir tyrannique et
pour désigner des institutions
françaises ces politiques
alors là ça s'assimilerait du
séparatisme de manière plus c'est ce
qu'on a appelé le salafisme non violent
et là où je pensais que sur les cinq
années écoulées je pensais que le débat
intellectuel parmi les chercheurs
notamment avaient enfin progressé qu'on
était d'accord pour dire que la rupture
symbolique peut provoquer la rupture
physique l'attentât là on en revient à
cette distinction anglo saxon entre
radicalisation non-violente
radicalisation violent la radicalisation
dit non violente
elle est violente symboliquement donc
donc cette différence me semble
extrêmement dangereux pour justifier
justement une hostilité à la loi sur la
position sur la loi voilà je parle en
tant que citoyens et plus et plus en
tant que chercheur il me semble qu'elle
ait qu elle va dans le bon sens dans la
mesure où elle reconnaît l'existence
d'un problème est qu'elle donne des
outils à au préfet notamment des
contrats pour respecter les valeurs
républicaines qui conditionne des
subventions publiques à des associations
des mesures en cas de carence
républicaine de substitution au maire je
pense qu'il ya une responsabilisation
que la loi au moins engage les acteurs
religieux à se responsabiliser et ne
peuvent pas ne pas me prendre conscience
de l'existence d'un problème et ils sont
oubliées sont mis devant leurs
responsabilités ce qui sera dit fait
diffuser dans la mosquée dans un don
viendront redevable auprès de auprès des
pouvoirs publics
déjà ce travail de responsabilisation
cette reconnaissance de l'existence d'un
problème à l'intérieur de la religion le
ne plus entendre l'habituel discours
c'est violent l'islam est une religion
de paix c'est violent donc c'est pas dit
slave
ça c'est un bon ça ne suffit pas donc à
chaque fois qu'un acte que violent et
commis au nom d'une idéologie ou d'une
religion
celui qui défend cette idéologie haussé
de cette religion doit et
damman faire un travail d'introspection
pour savoir comment ce qu'il à cette
tradition idéologique ou religieuse a pu
être exploitées à des fins à des fins
violentes
donc j'ai la responsabilisation est ce
que c'est trop tard non je bon je vais
pas assez des amas pente naturelle vers
la dépression le bec l'optimisme et
c'est ça il ya des lieux où c'est allé
dire plus préoccupant pour parler comme
les diplomates quand d'autres lieux mais
même en ces lieux préoccupant
je pense qu'il ya une comptine attente
considérable et que rien ne serait pire
que de se lancer dans ce que j'ai appelé
moi la politique des notables que en
passant des accords avec les
responsables associatifs l'ordonnant les
statuts de représentants soient locaux
soient nationaux non il ya une promesse
républicaine
il ya d un monde associatif il ya une
énergie il ya des gens qui demandent à
être français intégralement si j'ai
trouvé si facilement des étudiants prêts
à accompagner dans ce projet et qui
savait qu'il y aurait des conséquences
pour eux mêmes et pour moi c'est bien
qu'ils pensaient que c'était une des
manifestations de la promesse
républicaine
donc évidemment le grand problème que
nous avons c'est que je les dis ailleurs
invoqué de manière incantatoire les
principes de la république ne suffira
pas la grande le grand avantage de ces
islamistes et qu'ils peuvent se
rattacher
d'abord il nie évidemment là la
distinction islam islamisme et
prétendent parler au nom du véritable
islam et il se rattache à une grande
tradition des textes des épopées des
batailles des figures héroïques de la
poésie et donc quel imaginaire
on va opposer à cet imaginaire l'un qui
circulent qui met en scène le corps
le vêtement la nourriture le rapport à
l'autre etc
quel imaginaire dans un état nation en
crise
ça vous le savez mieux que moi le
chômage etc comment proposer de la
solidarité républicaine qui au moins
concurrence les solidarités islamistes
qui se joue dans les quartiers et là ça
c'est un travail d'euros j'allais dire
de reconnaissance d'euros compréhension
de la france je ne suis pas sûr que les
services de l'état connaissent très bien
le tissu social certains élus locaux
connaissent très bien évidemment aimé
mais les représentants de l'état
le renseignement territoriale qui est en
reconstruction les différents services
qui lutte surtout sur l'est évidemment
et c'est leur jeu et c'est leur rôle sur
les atteintes à la sécurité physique et
aux risques d'attentats
mais tout le reste c'est à dire la
compréhension de ce qui s'est passé sur
les 20 dernières années
la connaissance des réseaux la capacité
à la cartographier la connaissance de
l'arabe
tous ces éléments de quoi ne plus être
qu'un état doit se connaître sur sa
société pour pouvoir entre guillemets
l'administré au moins s'appuyer sur les
bons interlocuteurs identifier ceux qui
ont un projet idéologique etc
je crois que cette connaissance ou la
halle que les services de l'état ne
l'ont pas pour vous dire des choses peu
diplomatiquement où l'ont perdue ou en
tous les cas le long dans certaines
régions et pas dans d'autres
et ça dépend énormément des
personnalités ça dépend énormément de la
2de j'allais dire du sens de la mission
pour ça que j'avais parlé d'une
administration de mission reprenant la
vieille expression d'edgard pisani pour
une autre administration mais pour dire
qu'un travail comme ça doit être conduit
par des gens animés du désir de la
reconquête républicaine et qui sont
prêts à y passer du temps et à trouver
des interlocuteurs aller sur le terrain
connaître la situation avoir des
méthodes
tout ça est un est un travail
considérable il faut des gens qui
connaissent les lents il faut des gens
qui veulent un seul et culture que les
gens qui connaissent qui connaissent les
quartiers
c'est un vrai réseau de compétences à
mobiliser voyez le travail auquel on est
parvenu et nous étions cinq ou six mois
mon étaient cinq et ce travail là encore
une fois si j'avais pu travailler à
strasbourg à marseille je devrais
obtenir des résultats encore un corps
supplémentaires mais voilà un peu pour
répondre un peu de ce qu'ils aient moins
de 20 fautes de façon un peu rapide aux
diverses questions en espérant ne pas en
avoir oublié en chemin
merci monsieur auger y at il d'autres
questions d'autres réactions je sais est
ce que tu vas y sont touchées plus ou
moins d'accord entendu la question est
ce que tous les quartiers sont touchés
plus ou moins il faudrait d'abord
connaître toute la situation
ce qui est certain c'est que le fait
qu'on ait travaillé de manière aléatoire
et qu'on ait trouvé son pour prétendre
est déjà préoccupant alors il ya vous
savez il ya le conformisme ce que
j'appelais le fait que les diverses
différentes sources affirment la même
chose et que les gens considèrent que
c'est ça c'est d'islam et donc ce
travail là il a il est catastrophique
c'est ce que j'ai appelé aussi la
superposition des lieux de sociabilité
la mosquée le loisir la sandwicherie la
salle de sport
si on a dans le même espace si vous
voulez une sorte de diffusion de
solidarité qui s'opère avec un codage
islamique et religieux c'est très
difficile de casser ça parceque vous
l'intéressé aura le sentiment de quitter
le groupe
et comme on est une société où les gens
se sentent très vulnérables à cause des
2 du code vide à cause du chômage à
cause d'eux des diverses crises il ya le
besoin d'être protégée par le groupe
et là où c'est ce qu'on a pu observer
dans certaines communes je vais
volontairement ne pas les nommer parce
que
ces travaux me valent des procès il faut
bien voir que voilà dès qu'on travaille
là-dessus il ya la peur il ya
l'intimidation et il ya la menace
judiciaire par des 1/4 des associations
qui ont beaucoup plus d'argent que les
universitaires que nous sommes pauvres
universités françaises
donc il ya ça ira ça gérer et donc tout
ça pour vous dire que c'est une
situation évidemment difficile et et non
c'est pas perdu je pense pas du tout je
pense qu'il faut qu'il ya des chercheurs
courageux on n'est pas très nombreux à
florence bergeaud-blackler sur le canal
gomichon gilles kepel peut-être quelques
autres y compris à l'intérieur du champ
de la recherche on est extrêmement
attaquer et souvent insulter c'est même
pas une attaque c'est dans les quartiers
avoir des gens qui lui coule je pense qu
évidemment il y en a dans les quartiers
c'est toujours pareil c'est à dire c'est
qu'on peut créer des logiques
collectives s'il ya du courage et de
l'affirmation voilà faut pas que ce
soient des individus seuls c'est la
grande question j'ai pas reprendre
aggravée enfin mal commenté ce qui s'est
passé à trappes mais dans l'est dans les
déclarations ce qui est frappant c'est
que ce type de déclarations existent
sont on le pense minoritaire dire qu'il
ya des minorités actives qui travaillent
à séparer ses population allait les
englober derrière un collectif religieux
pour éventuellement parler en leur nom
face aux pouvoirs publics là on est dans
des logiques de lobbying et
communautariste en réalité la libanaise
si vous voulez mais c'est que les autres
ne parle pas c'est qu'ils n'ont pas le
langage ni le courage parfois pour dire
ce que tu dis est inadmissible mais je
les observais y compris dans mon
université
c'est à dire que je suis persuadé que la
plupart ya beaucoup de jeunes filles
dans les départements d'études arabes ne
sont pas d'accord avec les propos de tel
ou tel mais elle ya un effet
d'intimidation et un ami m'avait dit
comme définition de l'islamisme il
arrive à nous à nous faire honte en
essayant de souligner le fait qu'on soit
à l'extérieur de la norme et donc il ya
une espèce de chantage aux religieux à
la piété qui s'opère et donc il ya une
peur c'est pour ça qu'il faut il faut
casser cette peur assumer une autre
vision de l'islam voire ne pas être
religieux du tout si on ad'un de droit
pouvoir manger ce qu'on vaut manger
s'habiller comme on veut s'habiller sans
être dans des logiques de contrôle
social qui vont s'appuyer sur le
religieux tel qu'il leur a été transmis
pour semer une espèce de contrôle de
moralité islamique dans les quartiers
dans les universités par des remarques
et c'est donc ça c'est une voie là c'est
une dimension est là mais la voilà pour
jouer merci je suis vidé la parole à
madame lesage breniaux et j'ai comme une
question d'observation que vous êtes
attend une êtes enfin vous nous
expliquer exactement la manière dont les
les plus radicaux progresse en réalité
dans l'or dans leur idéologie et
manifestement la menace l'intimidation
la peur est un outil premier dans ces
conditions là quels sont les quelles
armes pouvant avoir pour lutter contre
cette cette manière de faire on peut se
renseigner sur plein de choses mais
finalement c'est une action sur sur les
consciences sur les personnes sur leur
mode de pensée et lire sur leurs
sentiments et c'est un difficile de
pouvoir lutter contre ça je dis pas que
ça n'existe pas qu'on n'a pas des moyens
mais qu'est ce qu'ils seraient les
moyens les plus efficaces
on avait juste avant vous à cette table
avec la commission de la culture
on a parlé éducation école enseignement
c'est sans doute une action de long
terme mais qui est absolument nécessaire
dont on sent bien aujourd'hui que ce
soit dans le monde de l'éducation dans
le monde sportif
la république est démuni en réalité
à défaut d'être démunis elle a peut-être
pas pris conscience de l'ampleur de la
situation et n'est d'ailleurs qu'un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens n'ont
même pas conscience de la situation elle
même et n'ont même pas de sens mais
eux-mêmes armés pour armer au sens
intellectuel du terrain pour pouvoir
lutter contre ce dispositif
quelles seraient vos préconisations de
ce point de vue là active efficace qui
contrôle qui a pris vraiment le pouvoir
sur l'islam et sur des quartiers mais
qu'il y a
large attente d'autres choses la
question c'est comment donner forme à
cette attente par qui ça doit passer
d'après moi c'est là où il ya un travail
de connaissance du terrain il faut
identifier les personnalités
charismatiques qui ne sont pas dans ce
projet idéologique qui sont même hostile
c'est c'est c'est quand même étonnant de
voir que très souvent le ceux qui sont
les plus courageux dont le
contre-discours latitude de liberté sont
ceux qui ont connu la décennie noire en
algérie sont d'origine algérienne et qui
ont vécu dans leur chair le terrorisme
du gia ou l'intimidation du front
islamique du salut
donc ce souvent y compris des franco
algériens y compris dans l'état ont plus
d'expérience et plus de connaissances et
de finesse dans la lignée d'une
situation que ceux qui n'ont pas connu
ça donc il faut j'allais dire réactiver
les expériences de ce type donner des
perspectives mais ça ça demande des
moyens évidemment il y en a pas beaucoup
dans le monde associatif à ceux qui ne
se prévalent pas de ces valeurs là mais
d'autres valeurs plus proche des valeurs
républicaines
tout ce qui est dans l'ordre du sport de
la solidarité de quartier de l'entr'aide
du soutien scolaire doit être qu'ils
sont des fonctions sociales que les
islamistes
évidemment assurent elles doivent être
assurées par d'autres cadres
donc il s'agit d'identifier dans un
espace dans un territoire particulier
qui opère ses fonctions et qui et
comment on peut voir qu'il ya un danger
dans telle ou telle activité sportive
activités d'entr'aide et au moins la
combattre de l'intérieur la loi devrait
le permettre et créer d'autres
structures ont encouragé la création
d'autres structures qui ne porterait pas
le même discours et qui seraient
identifiés comme tels dans les
territoires et à ce moment là comme des
acteurs concurrents encore une fois des
acteurs religieux communautaires et
autres donc ça passe par ça peut aussi
passer vous allez trouver sa paradoxale
probablement mais comme l'inde le
travail de ces opérateurs ces deux-là
contre socialisation qu'ils font en
réalité
de là contre socialisation républicaine
mais qui est aussi une trahison souvent
des origines ethniques et des traditions
des parents des grands parents l'a pas
le rôle de l'état de réactiver les
traditions en afrique subsaharienne etc
mais des associations qui s'en occupent
verrez également que leur expression
confrérique l'or sont attaqués et de
manière très violente par les
prédicateurs salafistes par exemple donc
les identités ethnoculturelles porté par
la famille sont aussi les cibles du
discours je dis pas qu'il faut
nécessairement les réactiver si vous
voulez mais les mémoires familiales
peuvent aussi porter des leçons contre
ce type d'acteur voyez il y a je pense
été des leviers associatif qui passe par
la connaissance intime du tissu par une
longue expérience du terrain alors il ya
aussi le problème des nominations
administratives c'est souvent quatre ans
donc en quatre ans on a juste le temps
de comprendre et puis ensuite on doit
partir et donc il faut c'est une action
qu'il faut mener avec une mémoire longue
et le problème de notre état c'est alors
les élus peuvent la voir la mémoire
langue s'ils sont là et lui mais mais
très souvent les représentants de l'état
ne l'ont pas donc tout ça demande un
travail de connaissance
un travail de confiance s'appuyer sur
des acteurs prendre le risque de
provoquer des paroles alternative
demandé à nos orientaliste musulmans
d'aller porter le discours de
déconstruction de l'islamisme dans les
quartiers garantir l'autonomie afin de
garantir la liberté universitaire et les
postes d'islamologues d'islamologie que
ces postes soient pas convoité par des
acteurs religieux avec un agenda est
dont ils veulent se saisir parce que
c'est l'un des derniers lieux
institutionnels
on peut déconstruire c'est le
raisonnement et les raisonnements
islamistes pour produire une autre une
autre vision d'islam donc un contre
discours sur le plan théologique et pour
l'état des lieux de sociabilité des
perspectives réelles
le qui renouvelle en quelque sorte le
pacte républicain ce sont des formules
un peu mais qui lui parviennent à
l'incarner avec des contres modèle il y
en a aussi un je pense que ce sont il ya
des jeunes issus de l'immigration aux
musulmans qui se reconnaît absolument
pas danser dans ses discours et ses
pratiques et c'est eux qu'il faut mettre
en avant
il faut de toute manière l'état est mis
au défi d'intervenir l'état les
collectivités locales les élus les
institutions sont mises au défi
d'intervenir c'est une question ou la
fin nous n'avons plus le choix je pense
on regarde madame lesage réunion de
seconde parce qu'on a encore une
audition d'avoir cité propos que voilà
je reviens ce témoin ce que je voulais
et filmant partager ce que ce que disait
le président de la commission des lois
l'instant le problème que nous avons
basculé
je pense que beaucoup de gens ne ne
mesure pas ne mesure pas combien il est
difficile de résister à ces gens dans
les quartiers
combien c'est difficile d'exister
autrement et combien de jeunes en
particulier les filles en particulier se
construisent une vie parallèle dans ces
quartiers pour ne pas subir
est ce que vous disiez à l'instant
professeur c'est important bien
évidemment dans ces quartiers ya des
jeunes qui réussissent les jeunes qui
sont de confession musulmane
sauf que cela ils s'en vont dès qu'ils
peuvent ils s'en vont dès qu'ils peuvent
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas lutter ils
ne peuvent pas parce qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une telle pression et c'est là
l'enjeu de cette loi je sais pas si on
va y arriver
et l'enjeu du futur c'est de dire
comment on casse cette intimidation
permanence il faut pas être beaucoup
pour faire peur à une cité un faux pas
être nombreux ce que je pense que
beaucoup n'imaginent pas quel point tout
ça fonctionne comme ça comment ça
fonctionne et le problème c'est que
quand les jeunes réussissent ils s'en
vont et les filles elles n'ont qu'une
envie c'est d'aller ailleurs
donc ça c'est un vrai vrai sujet je
pense que vous dites là l'essentiel
mais que celles et ceux que l'on
voudrait voir se réinvestir dans les
quartiers s'ils ne sont pas soutenues
par la puissance politique et publique
ils n'y arriveront jamais vraiment moi
je pense
ce que vous dites c'est essentiel merci
même le rapporteur oui je suis de
l'autre question mal à mercier oui merci
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le professeur de vos
connaissances manifestement extrêmement
imprécises et fondez vous avez dit que
l'administration probablement ne
connaissait pas ces quartiers nokia j'ai
plus presque envie de vous dire ou ne
veut pas connaître ou ne veut pas
connaître pour avoir été maire d'une
commune je dirais lambda quand j'ai eu
des soucis des soucis de mariages
arrangés que j'ai appelé le procureur en
disant ça mais j'ai un doute sur l'amour
qui existeraient marié les madame le
maire ok quand j'ai eu un jour une
prière dans ma mairie avec les hommes
d'un côté les femmes de l'autre 50
hommes qui prient dans la mairie que
j'ai alerté le sous préfet mais en
monsieur le sous préfet que dois-je
faire le sous préfet m'a répondu vous
n'auriez jamais laissé dû faire ça
voyons vous avez mélanger le temporel et
l'intemporel que pouvais-je faire avec
ma petite secrétaire de mairie
que pouvais-je faire je nous n'étions
pas d'écrire comme il ya des gens qui ne
nous sert pas la main qu'on a l'air trop
dit mais qu'est-ce qu'on comment
pouvez-vous nous aider quand on va faire
des contrôles dans les appartements des
contrôles de d'éducation et qu'on
prévient la zenn en octet ya un problème
et trois petites filles sont bien rangés
sur le canapé rien ne dépasse là
manifestement elle après l'un on ne veut
pas voir
est ce que quand on fait toutes ses
actions d'intégration dans nos quartiers
avec des petits déjeuners à l'excès on
sait très bien qu'il ya des familles
qu'on ne touche pas mais on n'y arrive
pas donc c'est vrai qu'il ya des
chercheurs très courageux je vous
félicite je vous remercie aussi des élus
qui essaye de faire quelque chose mais
quand vous voyez que l'administration
nous lâche on a aussi envie de lâcher et
de ne plus demander ces enquêtes pour
les mariages arrangés par exemple tiens
à remercier rien je crois oui mais
est ce que le fait de tenter puisqu'il
ya une réflexion sur la formation des
imams
est ce que c'est une chose qui qui est
possible d'ailleurs au niveau de la
religion musulmane de se dire on va
former des imams en france et on
imposera qui seront les imams officiel
oui ça c'est tout à fait possible dans
l'histoire de l'islam il ya une
pluralité de courant il ya des vous
savez même pas ce qu'on a appelé la
jurisprudence classique c'est dur
expériences classiques
elle a toujours nié ça va parler aux
juristes le caractère comment vous dire
universel des solutions de droit qu'il
proposait au règlement d'un litige et
ils ont toujours dit c'est notre
décision est inspirée de la loi
religieuse mais notre décision
elle est évidemment le fruit d'un effort
de transposition de cette foi religieuse
dans un cas d'espèce et que nous ne
prétendons pas du tout que la solution
nous allons donner est valable en tout
lieu et en tout temps
donc ces temps il ya une herméneutique
qui a été j'allais dire favoriser très
rapidement dans l'histoire de l'islam
donc il ya un héritage le problème de
ces acteurs et à l'héritage de très
grande richesse et pluralisme le
problème de sélecteur c'est qu'ils
prennent une seule partie de la
tradition 7 qui est le plus proche de ce
qu'il préconise et qu'ils ignorent tout
ce qui ne va pas dans leur sens
donc au moins dans les dires de 2,2 de
faire connaître la richesse de cette de
cette jurisprudence de cette histoire
intellectuelle aux imams plus la
connaissance de la france des notions de
sciences sociales des notions de droit
public
ça me paraît un travail indispensable
absolument indispensable à faire ça
permettra au moins même aux intéressés
de comprendre là où il ya un coup de
force
pourquoi ça c'est une interprétation ce
n'est pas l'islam c'est toujours le
vieux problème en anthropologie
c'est de savoir est ce que l'islam c'est
ce que les musulmans font ou est-ce
qu'on est musulman parce qu'on suit
l'islam
évidemment si vous êtes islamistes vous
allez dire on est musulman parce qu'on
suit l'islam toi tu es un mauvais
musulman où tu as tu n'es plus musulman
évidemment nous du côté des sciences
sociales et ans à dire l'islam c'est ce
que les musulmans en fou et jonquilles à
7 c dialectique entre ces deux c'est de
ces deux éléments entre le moment on va
vers la fois le moment on va vers
l'observation des sciences sociales
mais l'idée c'est de ces deux de ces
deux je vous dis la prise de conscience
me paraît fondamental la responsabilité
des acteurs dans leur formation de leurs
propres cadres est quelque chose de
fondamental
on ne pouvait pas laisser la situation
en l'état ça veut pas dire que ça va
fonctionner il y aura des tentatives de
contournement notamment par certains
états mais au moins encore une fois ça
ça pose le problème et ça met les
acteurs devant le reste leurs
responsabilités mais madame quand vous
dans votre témoignage
oui j'ai été peut-être injuste en
réalité il ya des agents publics qui
connaissent très bien la situation
mais c'est un savoir qui n'a pas été
synthétisé en quelque sorte
ce sont des frustrations accumulées par
d'état d'agents dans les mairies en
particulier qui savent exactement ce qui
s'est passé qui ont du coup de choses à
dire avec un climat d' omerta qui peut
et qui peut régner ici et là donc il ya
une expérience en réalité de l'état ou
des collectivités locales vous avez
raison de le dire
vous avez raison de le dire mais que
cette expérience il faut qu'elles soient
restitués votre témoignage imaginer les
que j'ai entendue vers d'anciens
employés municipaux direction des
affaires culturelles etc tous âges en
temps exact dès qu'il parle et s'il part
quand ils sont plus en fonction dans la
plupart des cas ils me disent je ne
pouvais d'abord il faut que sastre est
anonyme et 2
je peux parler maintenant parce que je
n'y suis plus donc là il ya un problème
il ya un vrai savoir et une frustration
accumulée par des agents publics qui
mériterait peut-être delà des produits
quelque part d'abord ça ferait une
matière extraordinaire pour la recherche
et ça leur permettrait de mettre en
valeur cette expérience accumulée
là il ya quelque chose là il ya un
problème réellement dans les collectifs
dans les mairies en particulier
[Musique]